i la parole est maintenant notre
collègue jean noël cardoux pour le
groupe l'est républicain
mais ma question s'adresse à madame
ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement le baril le parlement le
parlement a adopté la loi sur la
biodiversité dont la pierre angulaire
devait être la création de l' agence
française pour la biodiversité
durant l'été vos services ont communiqué
à ce sujet le contour des objectifs et
le financement de cette agence demeurent
floues les dirigeants de la chasse oncfs
et fnc n'ont pas voulu l'intégrer en
attendant d'y voir plus clair
vous avez souhaité qu'un dialogue
constructif avec le fils interviennent
en vue d'aboutir à des conventions
particulier concernant la police de
l'environnement
or viennent d'être nommé à la tête de
cette agence l'ancien président et
l'ancien directeur de l'ex rassemblement
des opposants à la chasse associations
militantes associations militantes
représentant moins de 2000 personnes
dont la dénomination se suffit à
elle-même
pensez vous que ces nominations soit
opportune pour est d'appeler un dialogue
constructif avec les acteurs cynégétique
de terrain et permettront de rassurer le
monde rural dont la chasse et la pêche
sont des composantes essentielles
pouvez-nous nous préciser les objectifs
et la feuille de route que vous allez à
signer à l' agence pour la biodiversité
dans les mois à venir bien bon vous
répondre la parole et madame le team
voltaire mais le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur je dois
tout d'abord excusé l'absence de
ségolène royal qui m'a demandé de porter
la réponse à sa place l' agence
française pour la biodiversité a été
créée par par la loi qui a été constant
sur la biodiversité de la nature et des
paysages a été promulguée effectivement
cet été le 8 août précisément pour
lutter contre la perte de biodiversité
et répondre aux enjeux d'adaptation aux
effets du changement climatique
l'agent ce sera un opérateur de
référence au service d'un nouveau modèle
de développement elle exercera une
démission de préserver
lyon de gestion et de restauration de la
biodiversité permettra le développement
des connaissances la gestion équilibrée
et durable des eaux et la lutte contre
la biopiraterie l' agence pour la
biodiversité est issue de la réunion de
quatre organismes engagés dans les plus
hauts les politiques de biodiversité
l'office national de l'eau et des
milieux aquatiques
l' agence des aires marines protégées
l'établissement des parcs nationaux de
france et l'atelier technique des
espaces naturels
c'est pas une réponse à la question mais
si on vous interrogez monsieur le
sénateur je suis pas sûr que vous
pourriez la donner sans attendre sans
sans attendre le vote de la loi pour la
reconquête de sa diversité de la nature
et des paysages
le gouvernement a voulu que les travaux
de préparation de la mise en oeuvre de
cette loi soient mises en oeuvre
c'est pourquoi et notamment a voulu que
l'agent soit en fonctionnement au 1er
janvier 2010 est pour cette raison
ségolène royal et barbara pompili ont
réuni le 7 septembre dernier le conseil
d'administration transitoire et par la
loi pour débattre avec les
administrateurs des questions de
gouvernance et des prix il faut conclure
lagence le conseil d'administration
définitif est composé de cinq collèges
je voulais conclure en vous disant et en
vous rappelant qu'à la demande des
représentants des chasseurs l'office
national de la chasse et de la faune
sauvage n'est pas intégré dans l' agence
et il faut maintenant que l' agence
s'engage dans des actions concrètes et
très rapidement et elle sera prête pour
le 1er janvier
monsieur le sénateur merci monsieur
kardous
mais merci madame le ministre d'avoir
répété ce que je venais de dire donc je
pense que nos collègues auront apprécié
ce que je veux simplement observer c'est
que ce que vous nous dites est à
l'opposé de ce que le président de la
république avait déclaré concernant le
monde de la chasse et quelques thors
l'objectivité scientifique doit dépasser
l'activité militante ce n'est pas le
choix qui a été fait et je le déplore
comme le manque de concertation
pour preuve la volonté du ministre
établir une réserve naturelle nationale
dans l'estuaire de la loire
contre l'avis de la quasi totalité des
acteurs de terrain y compris les députés
des députés de la majorité actuelle nous
sommes bien loin du dialogue voulu entre
les utilisateurs de la nature
merci